the only cop car test Irvine hug Dyson
offer reminds us that spring is a season
of change for our cars as well and
winter salt and grit damaged paintwork
and windows and lights and battery take
a beating too he shows how to get your
car in shape for spring prevent a
buildup of harmful mold or bacteria in
the car make sure to completely dry out
carpets outside the car use newspaper to
soak up any moisture then assign know if
there's still moisture line hopes advice
is to clean the drain openings under the
door as these can become blocked that
doesn't help take it to the mechanic
give the trunk a good tidying up extra
baggage means extra gas
when's that dip even if your trunks
already empty it's always worth going in
to check if your first-aid kid is in
date now it's off to the car wash for a
good spring clean to remove any salt
grit and stubborn dirt and it's worth
doing properly so invest in a program
which includes a pre clean and under
body wash it's the only way to
completely remove winter salt and
prevent rust
it's important to pre-wash with a high
pressure cleaner before entering the car
wash otherwise dirt can act like
sandpaper and cover the car and
scratches let be gentle and only spray
each area once hold the hose at least 30
centimeters away and keep it moving to
prevent damage to the bodywork
never aim directly at the tires as this
can cause permanent damage keep at least
50 centimeters away
it's best to leave the engine to a
professional because it's easy to get it
wrong a high pressure cleaner is likely
to cause damage especially if you're not
an expert
now it's time to give the car a
once-over it's important to check the
windshield for chips because they can
lead to cracks for large scratches or
cracks you'll need an expert to repair
or replace it most car washes don't get
windows thoroughly clean you'll need
elbow grease for that
trauma reinhold explains how important
it is to clean the inside of the
windshield too because a greasy film can
build up during winter and can lead to
visibility problems when the Sun is low
in the sky the windshield wipers also
need to be checked because they've been
battling with ice and snow all winter if
they leave a residue this can be cleaned
with a soft cloth that the wipers are
chipped or broken then it's best to get
yourself a new set
there's aa nothing he also advises you
to grease the hinges to prevent
squeaking it's good for your car and
your nerves you can really hear the ones
on the hood so give them extra special
attention the air filter also needs
replacing moist winter air puts strain
on it and it can quickly become a
breeding ground for bacteria a new
filter also keeps spring pollen at bay
by hope also reminds us to make the
switch to summer tires inspect your
winter tires for damage and make sure
the tread isn't warned he explains the
three things which can cause this
incorrect air pressure faulty shock
absorbers or incorrect alignment just
remember to retighten the wheel nuts
after 50 kilometers and you're all set
for your summer drive some also protects
me and Vic